joining me in the studio is martin von
bergen he heads the department of
proteomics at the helmholtz center for
environmental research in leipzig
now we've heard a lot more is being
understood but have we really revealed
the secret of life with proteomics oh
i'm afraid not but we have made a great
step
now we can
detect and quantify much more proteins
than we could do before
but in order to really know how they
work we actually should understand their
interactions too right yes you're right
but this is always a discrepancy between
abundance of proteins and their function
but the first step is always to detect
and quantify the abundance of proteins
and from this on we can take the next
step
and then we have all those
billion cells in our body do they
actually all show different proteins too
yes but this is also this this is also
one of the results of the study that
with the compilation of so many
different
analyses from different tissues they can
now compare the abundancy of many many
proteins
among the different tissues
but does that actually mean that the
proteins i have and the proteins you
have are pretty similar how much do they
differ yes they
are pretty similar and the
similarity is
nearly as high as it is in the genome
the difference between us is less than
point five percent oh only much less and
what will it take and what do we have to
understand about the proteome
in order to develop therapies do we have
to know all these small differences
between us this is something which all
no i guess we don't have to because what
we see in the disease cases
is that the changes that occur are quite
similar between both of us so
and
you can identify proteins that are
crucial for the development of a disease
that are present in all or in most of
the cases of a disease
and if you then target these proteins by
a specific therapy then you might have
the chance to get a personalized and
very specific and hopefully
even more effective therapy than before
so this might be the first step to a
real personalized medicine yes i think
it is you now have the chance to compare
protein profiles on a very broad scale
and this will allow to find out which
proteins are predictive
for the success of a certain therapy and
how far is that away till my doctor
really uses it i don't know i don't know
how he got a doctor but i i assume that
it might take five to ten years okay but
that means we can actually expect i mean
it will very soon we'll all have our
genome sequenced will we also have our
proteome decoded then in the future
yes i guess we can expect that
so but that's actually then just a
matter of time till the machines and
technology is being developed yes and
once you have defined the profiles that
are specific for a certain disease you
can then restrict the analysis on a
selected
group of proteins which then can be much
more easier and faster detected
thanks a lot for the talk martin for
bear thank you very much